emigration is a lot of work
organizationally physically and
emotionally the home all family is
packing up to move the whole name has to
fit on the box so our forty second box
is finished the Blues malls are a Jewish
family they've lived in the Paris suburb
of pro tool for more than ten years the
children were born here the family runs
a thriving business selling motor
scooters but they say it's time to leave
if you wear a yarmulke and the Paris
métro you will not be attacked but
people gawk at you it's hard to endure
those looks it depresses and frightens
the family to see graffiti defacing
Jewish owned shops anti-semitism seems
to be on the rise in France there are
clear historical parallels these slogans
scrawled on stores owned by Jews we saw
that back in the 1930s one day we'll
wake up here and see a new pogrom a new
night of broken glass that could happen
in France today many young Jews say they
no longer feel safe especially in
socially depressed neighborhoods some
young Muslims have brought the
israeli-palestinian conflict into the
French suburbs and they have support
from left-wing pro-palestinian groups
which sometimes also set the tone at
universities that makes some Jewish
parents worry about their children's
educational future my children will soon
go to college I don't know how that will
turn out we all know what's happening at
the universities these days my children
will not be able to say openly that they
feel tied to Israel or even just that
they're Jews people will point them out
and the other students will provoke them
could you dwell misery cow the smear
campaign against Jews is not limited to
the left-wing extremist scene comedian
dieudonné m'bala m'bala fills whole
concert halls with his anti-semitic show
hundreds of thousands of French people
have visited the internet pages of
right-wing extremist intellectual Allah
so ha he openly praises Hitler for
example saying the Nazis construction of
highways to the east rescued the German
economy so ha likes to present
photographs of himself in the ragged
uniform of a concentration camp inmate
Antoni an architectural draftsman from
southern France is one of many French
adherents of right-wing views no one has
anything against the average Jew that
would be unjust the attacks here focus
on a very few people the Jews at the top
of the heap in our whole current system
growing numbers of people in France are
starting to believe in anti-semitic
conspiracy theories the climate has
changed more and more people think
Durden is appalling anti-semitic jokes
are harmless it's a kind of Jew hatred
light then more and more Frenchmen now
accept but for the Jews it's a very
serious matter of course violent attacks
on Jews are also increasing in broad
daylight on the streets and even in
their homes a month ago three young men
entered this apartment building ranks
emo and malice doorbell and assaulted
him when he opened the door
GGC slipped
and while I was falling I just managed
to get in a punch then I lay on the
floor and they were all beating and
kicking me with their hands and with
their feet all three of them Amala
called out to his son for help and the
attackers fled but since then he's lived
in fear they could return the wahoo
Schmauss family originally came from
Morocco his father was a printer and
worked hard to move up in the world he
taught his son to love French literature
and philosophy the prospect of moving
far away from French culture depresses
Lowell surely it'd make a father
I wish the French had shown us that we
were welcome here after all I'm French -
angry and sad I have to leave some of my
relatives behind and I have to give up
my job I go with a heavy heart started
couple no no but I have to think of my
children me I don't know whose son al is
glad to go in the future he'll be able
to wear a yarmulke without being
harassed call me lover
I really feel at home in Israel I love
France too but I feel better in Israel
there I can say what I feel and the
other people think like I do life will
be better there they've really moved all
around other families will be following
their whole Schmalz
they can no longer live without fear in
France even though it's their home